now i've talked about right-sided
abdominal pain but i really haven't
talked too much about pain on the left
side other than
maybe one video and it's really hard to
find so this video is on
what happens if you have pain underneath
the rib cage on the left side what could
that be
you have the liver here you have the
pancreas here so your liver is right
here and your pancreas is on the left
side
you have the gallbladder on the right
side and then you have all these little
tubes
that help drain bile biles made
in your liver it drains through these
little tubes they're called ducts
and most of it gets stored in the
gallbladder and it's concentrated by
five to seven times so then when you eat
it gets contracted
and it squeezes out through here into
your small intestine
well you also have a pancreas that makes
enzymes
so the enzymes especially like when
you're dealing with
fats the pancreas releases the enzyme
called lipase
which helps break down the fats but
there's other enzymes as well that are
created by the pancreas and secreted
if you look at this area right here
which is kind of right in your
below your stomach area right here in
the mid part
you have a joining of these
bile ducts with the pancreatic ducts
so if by chance there's some type of
gallstone or obstruction
in the in these pipes right through in
here or down here
there's going to be back pressure that
goes into the pancreas
because these enzymes are now dissolving
and irritating
itself so typically pancreatitis
comes from either way too much alcohol
or
gall stones but up to 40 percent of the
time
there's an idiopathic cause and that
means unknown cause
but if you look up more data on this
there's an indication that you have
something called biliary sludge
it's kind of a pre-state or a pre-gall
stone
where you're getting this thickened bile
sludge
that is very hard to detect on either a
cat scan
mri or even ultrasound because the
crystals are very very small
and i'm going to put a link down below
if you want more information about this
but
what happens if you have sludge that's
kind of clogging up these little pipes
right here
and you have these little valves that
might not close properly we're not
getting the drainage it can back up and
create
this right here so this sludge
is concentrated cholesterol crystals
this does not come from having high
cholesterol
or consuming too much dietary
it comes from having a lack of bile
because it is the bile
that is a key thing in your body to help
regulate this
amount of concentrated cholesterol it's
the bile that helps
keep the cholesterol thinned
and when you're lacking bile your risk
for
gall stones increase you get more
bilirubin sludge
and you start getting these crystals the
solution is not necessarily to
go on a low cholesterol diet it's to add
more purified bile salts because when
you do that
that will help to thin this cholesterol
bile material and allow drainage to
occur
but if we go deeper and talk about what
you need to do to make sure that your
body produces more bile there's several
things that you can do
cut your carbs down that's called
healthy keto do intermittent fasting
cut down the amount of grains that you
consume because when you increase
grains you increase insulin and too much
insulin can deplete your bile reserve
also too much estrogen can do it too so
if you're taking birth control pills
or even when a woman is pregnant and she
has a spike in estrogen
that can mess with the bile that's why
women that are pregnant
have a higher risk of getting gallstones
same thing with women that are taking
estrogen replacement therapy
vegetable oils are omega-6 highly
inflammatory
this can also increase insulin and
create insulin resistance
which then creates a problem with that
having too many
nuts or nut butters
can give you too many omega-6 fatty
acids and irritate this area right here
of course we talked about alcohol you're
going to have to
cut down your alcohol to no more than a
six-pack on a weekend
number seven corn most corn
is gmo that means it has glyphosate
which is very irritating to the inner
lining of your bile ducts right through
in here
also it's a carbohydrate and then of
course
taking purified bile salts this would be
very very important
take one in them in the morning on an
empty stomach and take one
in the evening on an empty stomach and
that can gradually help keep this flow
opened and keep it drained and reduce
the inflammation
all right thanks for watching before you
go
if you have a question about a product
or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help